[Aplausos]
les voy a contar una historia de un
amigo como seguramente ustedes tienen un
amigo parecido los amigos que se
preocupan mucho por su salud
constantemente trata de cuidarse y se
hace exámenes porque por ahí dicen que
lo que no se examinan no se puede
mejorar entonces resulta ser que justo
esta semana a mi amigo le toca hacerse
unos análisis y él sabe que pues en los
últimos días no ha cuidado su dieta no
está haciendo ejercicio se ha desvelado
y entonces ha tenido hasta unos
malestares y sabe que si va ahí se hacen
los exámenes de esta forma pues va a
salir más y entonces él no quiere salir
mal en sus exámenes y me habla y me dice
oye boliver fíjate que me voy a hacer
los exámenes pero no quiero salir mal
entonces no sé si tú me puedas echar la
mano no sé si tú me puedes prestar pues
un poquito de tú
de tus análisis no
y entonces bueno hay perdón es que esto
es un poco de trabajo estar dando la
conferencia con esto aquí
ah
y entonces yo le digo oye digo oye tú
estás loco que está bien que seamos
amigos pero de eso a hacerlo de a gratis
no sé a eso se cobra y si no me creen
que por eso se cobra para eso son
exactamente
algunas de las páginas que les voy a
mostrar aquí como te hago tu tarea en
línea mister texto y todas ellas se
dedican a hacer exactamente lo mismo que
me pidió mi amigo quizá algunos de
ustedes piensen no no no oye le estás
confundiendo las cosas lo que tu amigo
te pidió fue hacer trampa para salir
bien en sus exámenes médicos y aquí lo
único que es es que te ayuden a salir
bien en tus exámenes
y por cierto se cobra desde 350 personas
simple tarea hasta 10.000 cuando pides
hacer una tesis
entonces
yo digo durante diez años me tocó dar
clases y yo siempre trataba de darles
esta analogía a los chicos yo les decía
si ustedes copian el examen es como si
vas con el doctor y luego le mientes
acerca de tus síntomas cómo crees que te
va a ayudar a mejorar lo que sea que
tengas y bueno uno puede decir bueno
quizá es un pequeño número de personas
los que están haciendo ese tipo de cosas
de la copia
salió una noticia de que hicieron un
examen en línea en la universidad de
guadalajara estaba diseñado el examen
para que lo hicieran aproximadamente en
dos horas y de repente sacó una alerta
del sistema porque estaban terminando el
examen en cinco minutos
tuvieron que ponerle 0 a 504 alumnos
porque fueron los que confesaron que
habían hecho trampa para hacer ese
examen o sea que no son tan poquitos los
alumnos uno puede pensar buenos que son
los chicos o ya no saben todavía no
saben de la importancia de hacer bien
las cosas de copiar a quién podemos
recurrir
recurramos a los padres esta foto que
les estoy mostrando son papás todos
ellos ahí jugándose la vida y ese es una
escuela y uno decir inocentemente de
seguro se les olvidó algo a los chicos
están trepando ahí por las paredes para
llevarle su lonche no vaya a ser que se
queden sin comer los muchachos en
realidad lo que están haciendo es
subirse ahí para pasarle las respuestas
al examen
esta nota salió en los principales
medios internacionales pasó en la india
llevaron a la cárcel como a 70 papas
expulsaron a 300 alumnos
o sea que no podíamos recurrir en los
papás verdad
la imagen que les voy a mostrar
seguramente les es familiar algunos ya
la han visto pero lo curioso de que les
quiero mostrar es que está en diferentes
idiomas lo que quiere decir es que si
usted se puede investigar esto es algo
generalizado no solamente pasa en mexico
no solamente pasa en latinoamerica hemos
hecho tan importantes las evaluaciones
que nos hemos olvidado del conocimiento
y nosotros no nos damos cuenta que
cuando estamos en la escuela la
principal labor es tratar de preparar a
la nueva generación para que tome este
mundo y cuando nosotros enseñamos que lo
más importante no son las métricas y no
lo que hay detrás de ellas lo que
estamos enseñando es que el fin
justifica los medios y luego nos
sorprende que los chicos salgan y no les
importe si hacen trampa si hay
corrupción si lastiman a otra persona si
dañan al planeta cuando nosotros les
enseñamos que lo más importante son las
metas
es tan importante para los muchachos
tener una buena calificación porque
cuando tú eres chico y ustedes tratan de
recordar cuando estás en primaria cuando
estás en secundaria cuando eres niño
cuando eres joven casi la mitad del
tiempo la pasas en las escuelas casi la
mitad de las evaluaciones acerca de lo
que eres viene con estas dos cosas te va
a ir bien si eres lindo si eres
físicamente atractivo debe ir bien si
eres un buen estudiante vanas irá bien
en él es muy bueno ese aplicado así que
pobres de los chicos que les van mal en
la escuela y además son feos
menos mal yo no tenía que preocuparme
por eso
más bien tenía que estudiar un chorro
trate de imaginarse que cuando en la
escuela te dicen que sólo importa el
resultado que hay una respuesta buena y
que todas las demás están mal también lo
que te están enseñando es que no está
bien equivocarte te están enseñando a
tener miedo a fracasar por eso es que
luego no nos debe de extrañar que los
chicos no quieren emprender nuevas cosas
si les enseñamos todo el tiempo que si
se equivocan son unos fracasados está
mal
así los hacemos crecer así de los
hacemos crecer les voy a contar mi
historia cuando tengo 18 años estoy por
elegir mi carrera
me pasa el dilema de lo que yo llamo la
última bala de plata ya saben esa bala
de plata que puede matar cualquier
monstruo no esa bala de plata era elegir
la carrera si en algo puedo trascender
en este mundo no quiero equivocarme a la
hora de elegir la carrera voy a elegir
una en la que todas mis habilidades se
potencien y a mí se me ocurrió que lo
más inteligente era escoger la carrera
que era más difícil años más tarde me di
cuenta que era la forma más fácil de
demostrar que era tonto elegir una
carrera de algo que no amaba
pero ahí voy llego a esa carrera
ingeniero físico industrial lejos de mi
casa solamente se daba en monterrey
igual que yo llegaron muchos chicos que
tenían esa intención de intención de
trascender chicos que eran talentosos y
les voy a contar lo que nos pasó en el
quinto semestre un semestre que era muy
difícil para nosotros el semestre en
donde muchos de los chicos se cambiaban
otras carreras porque se habían dado
cuenta que era demasiado difícil les voy
a contar la historia de dos amigos que
tengo uno digamos que se llamaba lisanka
y el otro se llamaba rafael los dos
estamos por terminar ese semestre están
por reprobar cuatro materias
y lo que va a pasar les cambia a los dos
la vida por completo voy a contarles que
lisanka por ejemplo él había sido
seleccionado de matemáticas de química
de física por su estado o sea que no era
un chico tonto era un chico
que al menos parecía que era inteligente
había representado a su estado pero
había llegado a este punto donde le
estaba yendo mal al terminar el semestre
reprueba las cuatro materias al
siguiente semestre tratando de que no le
vaya tan mal pues escoge a los maestros
más barcos dije pues ahora sí no me voy
a hacer muy valiente y vuelve a reprobar
y entonces los compañeros también
empezamos a colaborar con lo que le pasó
porque entonces nosotros nos empezamos a
volar como crees te viste bien menso
pues sí si te metiste con el que era más
fácil hay todos pasan y poco a poco
entre las burlas de nosotros los
resultados que le iba teniendo se fue
volviendo un cielo obscuro cada vez
estaba más triste más distante reprobó
más materias cuando yo me gradué dos
años después de repente me llega a
facebook un grupo en donde es que se
llama por los que queremos que
finalmente se gradúe lisanga
lisanka se tardó dos años más que yo
para graduarse bueno
al menos eso decía el grupo
yo les voy a platicar que a él la
experiencia que tuvo de vida de haber
estado en la universidad
quizás no fue la mejor estoy seguro que
le pudo haber ido mejor si hubiera
elegido otra carrera otro lugar en donde
lo hubieran hecho sentir diferente en el
mismo semestre cuando empezó todo
rafael tiene igual cuatro materias que
está por reprobar él nunca había sido
seleccionado en matemáticas ni de física
era un chico inteligente
y ese semestre un concurso de
matemáticas se supone que no es de
nuestra materia estaban los más
inteligentes y nosotros nos imaginamos
que el concurso de matemáticas que era
en equipo lo iban a ganar los cerebritos
de nuestra carrera ya saben de esos
chicos que corren el ultramaratón hacen
la tarea antes de que te la pide el
profesor hacen acción social nosotros
dijimos ellos la van a ganar
y para sorpresa de todos
no la ganaron ellos ni la canalizan acá
me la gano rafael tampoco el store es
así pero lo sorprendente es que rafa
entró con chicos de otro semestre y aún
así quedó en tercer lugar es decir
aunque no había ganado había quedado más
arriba que los chicos que nosotros
considerábamos unos genios y ese momento
en su vida fue como una epifanía donde
algo directamente en el corazón de
rafael le dijo tú eres listo tú eres
bueno tú hueles la pena al final de ese
semestre de todas maneras reprobó tres
materias
pero de ese punto al final de su carrera
su promedio fue arriba de 90 y no volvió
a reprobar ninguna materia fue estudiar
una maestría eeuu estudió un doctorado
en eeuu de ingeniería de física y ahora
es un doctor muy respetado que
diferencias de historias no una historia
en donde cuando algo o alguien te dice
tú vales tú eres bueno y eso te levanta
y una historia donde estás escuchando
todo el tiempo eres malo vas a fracasar
vas a fracasar y miren lo que te pasa si
no pregunten el cruz azul
salió de la escuela y me toca ser
maestro y yo tenía esta historia de rafi
de lisanka bien metida había sido algo
que me había impactado yo había visto el
cambio en mis dos amigos y cuando entró
a trabajar el primer semestre me dice mi
jefe oye ahí en el grupo ten mucho
cuidado trata de ayudarle a ese chico y
lleva tres veces que ya reprobó la
materia no
que yo entro hasta atrás está el chico
ya saben si poniendo como una barrera
llegó y le preguntó oye pues cómo es
esto porque yo es la primera vez que voy
a dar clases tú ya llevas aquí 3
y trate de darle a él un rol diferente
yo sabía que él ya había cursado la
materia pero en vez de decirle oye estás
bien tonto pues es la tercera vez a poco
no lo sabes yo le dio un rol de decir tú
ya lo pasaste por aquí tú tienes que
ayudarle a los otros chicos oye pero tú
la tienes que ayudar tú ya estuviste
aquí y yo lo daba por entendido como si
él fuera bueno quizá todavía no era
bueno pero yo le daba entendido como que
está bueno si explicar a tus compañeros
ya les acabo sí sí sí ahí sigue bebiendo
a los chavos y yo veía a otros
no reprobó conmigo en la materia le fue
bien
conmigo no reprobó ya más matemáticas
después de que era la tercera vez que
cursaba esa materia estudió una
ingeniería hizo una maestría de
ingeniería y ahora a veces hasta que las
de matemáticas
y la verdad es que yo traté de ayudar a
cuántas personas podía con esto porque
sabía que más importante que los
contenidos están a lo que enseñamos a
veces cuando me iban a entregar un
examen le decía oye la chica se viene
está esta pregunta
quizá creo que ese signo está mal así
gracias y van
se supone que yo era de los maestros más
perros porque todo lo que les estoy
platicando no quiere decir que les ponen
unos exámenes fáciles pero les ayudaba
éste trataba de de alguna forma de
ayudarles porque yo sabía que cuando
ellas sacaban una buena calificación no
es que sacaron una buena calificación en
matemáticas es como si ellos hubieran
recuperado parte de su inteligencia es
como si todo lo que les habían dicho que
era tontos se los hubiéramos borrado y
eso es lo que mucha gente volviera a
recuperar su confianza como me hubiera
gustado poder ayudar a muchas más
personas
yo pienso que cuando somos maestros yo
después de esos 10 años tuve que salir
hace 5 años que no doy clases y una vez
que salí vi un mundo completamente
diferente cuando eres maestro a ti te
toca ver ese muchacho 35 horas cada
semana y tú construyes una idea de lo
que tú ves esas 35 horas si ellos no
tienen habilidades en lo que tú estás
explicando en lo que tú eres experto vas
a pensar que ellos son tontos no vas a
pensar que ellos no son tan buenos
hay muchas cosas en las que te pueden
enseñar y es lo que he visto ahora
cuando salgo a la escuela gente que
quizá batallaba conmigo en puestos
importantes siendo responsable llevando
liderazgo enseñándome cosas a veces
creemos los maestros que lo más
importantes son los contenidos que
estamos mostrando y los contenidos que
ahora mostramos realmente están algo al
alcance del google de la wikipedia se
nos olvida que la labor más importante
cuando estamos en la escuela es formar
personas a ser buenas personas
enseñarlas a que no tengan miedo a
fracasar a que se puedan levantar a que
sean resilientes a que respeten al otro
a que respeten el medio ambiente que no
hagan trampa
mientras tengamos un sistema educativo
que no esté cumpliendo esa función de
hacer buenas personas tenemos
constantemente que repensar lo evaluarlo
y cambiar lo que estamos enseñando en
las escuelas muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]